so just this top story uh this evening
that the police are saying that they
have no information that warrants a
criminal investigation into this BBC
presenter well that has been succeeded
by very significant news and Pa are
reporting that Vicki flind the wife of
the newsreader Hugh Edwards has named
him as the BBC presenter facing
allegations over payments for those
sexually explicit images in a statement
issued on his behalf so Hugh Edwards the
senior news reader of the BBC uh
presenter of the BBC six o'clock news
for a long time presenter of the BBC
News at 10 now
is has been named by his wife
as being the BBC presenter at the center
of all this